Fix the mic.
Okay,
yesterday I didn't quite finish this
debugging. I'd like to finish this today
and uh we will see what else I get done
from here.
I'd like to be a little bit more
principled about it though.
I feel a little bit better actually.
I feel a little bit better.
Hey, Weston.
11.375
per turn.
Okay.
If we choose to trust the RL for a
little bit here.
Turn this.
I just sat here. Hello vault.
How's it going, man?
Wednesday and stay like always. You're
working and doing um competition and
this right
evening to myself.
Good.
I want to get the inferno fully sorted
quite soon. I think like once we get it
nice and stable, it's going to be such a
good benchmark for um
uh for Puffer 5 dev. And also as an
extra fun bit for you, uh I think that
we can use the NH environment to test
our new selfplay stuff.
A job at a startup. Yeah,
there's a bunch of stuff.
Good on you.
That's very draining.
Yeah. So we have like pretty nice tested
selfplay.
Spencer has it almost done integrated
into 40. Jess has been doing a ton of
stuff on chess with it.
And we're looking for testowns. So, you
know, we get the Runescape stuffs
cleaned up. I got to actually really go
over observations and stuff with you at
some point because I think we can
probably make a big difference there.
But for now, I kind of just want to make
sure that we get the Inferno as a solid
test end.
out of it. I think I I took a quick look
at the leaderboard and you're way in the
lead, aren't you?
So, I think that there's only I think
that there's only one other guy who's
really trying because if I saw the
number three was literally just like,
"Hey, GPT, do this challenge for me.
I think observation design in general is
um it's sort of an open problem for us
and it's not feature engineering. Let me
be clear on that. It's much more so
stuff that has spatial and uh ordering
invariances.
Um preserving those with an efficient
net is very hard.
Still in stealth.
That's fair.
You would hope not.
That's kind of a shitty uh
shitty thing to do competitively.
so many obvious things.
Yeah, this is where visualization is
important.
And you see why we do so much stuff with
games, right? Because you can actually
visualize. I mean, imagine if we start
doing like heavy molecular sim, how
tough it'll be to figure out when stuff
is going Um,
some sense. This is so incredibly stupid
that this doesn't work here.
You were to buy a,000
thousand times.
Yeah,
I have that one allocated to YouTube for
that stuff. I do actually use the um the
six GPU box at the moment. I use it for
sweeping various ends.
broke something somehow. Damn it,
Spencer.
Well, I'm simultaneously brilliant in an
imbecile, it seems.
I'm going to highlight this exact line
here and um Spencer Jess and Vault, my
acolytes,
go ahead and see if you can figure out
why this environment was not learning um
with this. This was the fix.
Go ahead and see if you can figure out
why in this particular case it wasn't
learning. It's an energy trading
environment. It's buying and selling
energy and it's like a, you know, a
daily periodic curve. I'm going to go
get a set
Exobox is going to be way outside the
budget or need range at the moment.
Vault,
I also don't know about their whole like
treat this as one big GPU.
Well, guys, we found a new failure case
today
for RL.
Shall I explain what happened?
quite possibly vault. We'll see.
But a lot of the design of our stuff is
just like um
I genuinely
am not convinced that we're going to
need really big networks
to solve hard problems in the future.
Like I'm genuinely not convinced of it.
I'm convinced that we're going to need
some pretty crazy Sims,
but I'm actually not convinced that we
have to scale neural nets massively.
Okay.
Well, I should explain this now because
this is a pretty major finding. I mean,
it's kind of obvious in a sense and I
sort of wondered about this vaguely
before, which is why I caught it.
So, this was like a full day of
debugging
for this tidbit of knowledge.
Okay.
So you have an energy trading thing,
right?
So the price of energy
it varies like a sinoso sword, right?
And you want to buy here and you want to
sell here. So you know you can get this
as profit
very very simple task and we couldn't
learn this.
So here's what was happening
when you buy here you have a choice to
buy a specific amount of your capacity
and it was just giving you reward equals
some constant
times
uh delta dollars.
Very simple reward, right?
Now, what happens
when you exceed one here?
So, what happens if reward greater than
one
or conversely
reward less than -1.
So, what's going to happen here is let's
say it spends let's set reward equal to
-2
because it spends a bunch of money here.
Well, this gets clipped
and this goes to -1.
So, it should have gotten penalized by
two, but it only gets penalized by one.
And then it goes and sells it later, but
it's not going to sell it all at once.
It'll get reward equals 1. Reward equals
1. In fact, it doesn't even have to sell
it. Here is the crazy thing. It can
literally sell it right the next two
steps and it'll get reward one and one.
And then it just banks it banks this
profit of one because of the clipping.
So, it's a really easy to dis to
discover and very strong local optimum.
And uh in fact, this might even be
better than the so-called optimal
solution because you can just do this
like every single step, but it's not
going to be reflected in the episode
returns because the episode returns some
off of the environment and the clamping
happens during training.
So therefore, this gave the illusion
that the thing was completely broken
when in fact the RL is smarter than you
and it just finds a hack that you didn't
expect.
There you go.
So, I mean, this is a pretty strong
argument that we need to remove reward
clipping at some point.
Um,
one thing that makes me very happy is
the
what is it? The log soft. What's the uh
the [ __ ] scaling that that dude does?
Like the shitty world model paper.
There's some scaling thing in there. Any
any function that biases the reward will
have this problem. You can scale it by a
constant. Um, but that's all you can do.
So, I think we're going to have to do
something in the future with this.
The thing the point of clipping is if
the reward scale gets wrong, then that's
bad.
That shouldn't affect the episode per
return. This does affect the uh episode
return for end incorrectly. Spencer,
that's the problem because the reward
clipping happens in the training.
So mini research project is going to be
hill clipping.
And if anybody brings up that [ __ ]
dreamer Rick, they're getting flamed
because the only thing you can really
do, we could try something with like a
running average. We could try like a
fixed scale estimate. Um, but we can't
do any function that biases the returns.
25 million fishing XP on leagues.
Very nice.
See, now we have the problem that um
we're kind of washing out
the rewards.
This is learning though. It's just a
little fiddly.
of demonic packs. Not really, man. The
current progress is um just shy of rune
tier. I got 99 slayer on hydra
yesterday. I didn't really play very
long. I had like an hour after dinner.
Um,
passively doing herborn smithing with
the uh the butler buff
and farming will be
99 later today.
Uh,
anything else?
Yeah, fletching to 50 mil is solved. I
have infinite money off of um
transmuting runite ore. Uh, I'm
depending on how much farming I do, I
could technically get 200 mil rune
crafting XP in like 5 minutes as well as
50 mil prayer.
The only thing I don't have a good solve
for is um I don't know really what to do
about construction's kind of okay, but
then agility is a pain in the ass.
I'm having fun though. I kind of want to
use this as a like to practice some of
the uh pieces of content that we're
going to turn into ends. Like I kind of
wouldn't mind just doing the Zuck fight
on the main game a few more times.
I wouldn't mind kind of just having some
waves in which I can just try to flick
everything and see how hard it is.
how much of your knowledge you retain.
Like I hadn't done the Zuck fight in
four years and I did it no problem first
try with basically same DPS as main
game. Uh, I did triples first try
with no problem. Basically same DPS as
main game
and then all the new content that I
haven't done, it's like still hard even
with um even with all the buffs
like awakened Vard, awakened Leviathan
are still ridiculous,
but then like hard mode to is actually
very easy.
I actually my so my fourth run back into
hard mode to everybody screwed up the
soap maze and died. I managed to eat
through it and then I soloed like with
really shitty DPS. I soloed like 70% of
soap just tick eating all of the um
all the orbs. And I like literally had
not done that in four years.
Now granted, I did have two tick
clearance because I had combo eats, but
like come on. Still,
it's like eating I did eat like six or
seven orbs. Like no, like flawlessly
solo first try. I actually have not been
able to do um chamber solos is one of my
like most played pieces of content and I
couldn't do it when I came back. So, I
think the main reason I couldn't do it
was
um the
uh the staff change, right? No longer
having Sang and having an eye of Ajak.
The run is really different with a three
tick weapon.
I haven't sent any Tobitty
melee gear though. I do have a scythe if
you want to try sending some
top environment next. That'd be cool.
Four agent or we could do three agent or
four agent to as an environment.
One of the private servers has to have
code for it, right?
I also was pretty happy. So, my build
has lower DPS than the main meta thing
that everybody was doing, except in
rooms where I can abuse thorns. But with
the sages axe and just like sniping low
HP and with all the noobs dying
randomly, I was able I had like a there
was like a 10-man raid where I had a
third of the points in chambers. It was
pretty funny.
new raid when it comes out. That would
be actually very cool.
Haven't seen top on a private server.
Interesting.
Yeah, a lot of those mechanics are just
tough.
Doom is really funny on leagues because
you literally just face tank him. Like
you just thorns and face tank the
melees.
Right. So, I was trying to figure out
um
It should be easily learning this.
Still not for some reason.
someone accurate down quickly is going
to be too bad. I'd hope not.
To real would be terrible.
Yeah, but I don't particularly care too
much on that vault. Like I don't really
want to throw them on the main game
anyways.
I mainly just want players to not go,
hey, that's obviously wrong and that's
obviously wrong and whatnot.
Yeah, I'd rather people not have these
on the real game to be honest.
I'd rather this much be like a way
cooler like um you know this just
benefits the research.
Okay, so this does actually train. It
just takes it a while to figure [ __ ]
out.
We got some screwy hypers.
What if I just do this?
inconsistent actually.
I'll try this out.
vault.
I might be, it depends. I might also be
on the close to client work.
Okay, this is not used anywhere else
luckily.
signal is pretty tough. It's getting
washed out.
That's still like a very small reward uh
return scale.
Let me try these two separately.
Actually,
let me try these two separately.
a quite reasonable policy. I'd say on
its own.
We need to not spend all day on this. I
think that like we're kind of just
closing in on it being fine.
Okay. And now if I just set this one to
eight and I set these to four,
do them all to four.
We make 31k. Okay.
Look at the value loss here. You see the
problem?
This seems very odd to me that you can't
learn this.
Isn't it literally just deterministic
policy?
Hang on.
This doesn't match this. It's hacking.
We become uh foiled
by the agent being too smart.
It's because it's recognizing the
revenue up front.
Last move highlighting.
Cool.
Ah, cuz this one's just Isn't this one
just more variable?
Don't I?
What material are you using to study
these?
Uh, I'm not studying these, my guy. I'm
um
I build puffer lab. I build high
performance RL stuff. I've been doing
this for 10 years. I do have material
though for you to study it with. It's
free.
you just check my articles tab
x.com/juarez.
This has both a ton of research articles
as well as my guides that point you to
other resources and uh cover pretty much
everything you need to get started here.
The whole project's open source and
we've got tons of contributors, many of
whom are new.
Okay, much better. Right.
Get like um
way swingier
29 five. Well, it matches. I think it
matches.
but I think this is Like this is good
enough.
You can see it.
I think this is reasonable.
Okay. Um I'm going to commit this up.
Does anybody have stuff for me to
review? Because if not, then I'm going
to probably have to go work offstream on
the uh the closed source client work.
I'm trying to close out some stuff. But
if people have ends for me to review, I
will gladly do that first.
I have no idea what that that question
is.
How is no opera emergent? That doesn't
like that doesn't make sense.
Uh I So Spencer is not really here to
show me the code.
I chatted with him on call about the
design and stuff seemed reasonable.
He said that he broke sweeps, which is a
really bad thing to break. So, I'm
waiting for him to fix that and then
I'll just like review it and we'll merge
If you have clients that use puffer on
hardware,
I What?
What did you think of action masking?
Um, the way you did it seems reasonable.
Okay, that still seems like a spec
annoyance though, right?
We'll stream that. Of course, just no
reason not to.
All right, I think we're done then. So,
um I got some client work to do off
stream. This one I was able to stream
because it was uh open source end, but
next one's offstream
uh private project.
Anybody using puffer and companies feel
free to contact us if you have RL
projects and you'd like our assistance.
Um, for everyone else,
thank you for tuning in.
Two star the puffer on GitHub. It helps
us out a lot.
Join us on Discord, Fallen X, if you
want to get involved.
Probably going to be starting the next
block of research in a few weeks here.
And uh it's mostly going to be
about setting the state of environments
like using state sets to accelerate
learning
with probably a few other basic science
bits thrown in.
The thing from today was actually quite
disturbing with the um reward magnitude
screw-ups. I'm going to have to think
about that. Thank you.